I'm starting with a quote I just got
from from an ish which is let them
manage to get an opening idea nobody
gets opening ideas anymore no it's
interesting but generally I mean when
you play for a long time as I did you
have an idea in any opening that you
have previously played so this is an old
idea which I mean it's a very rare line
people now based on play not just a six
I mean but mainly 27 they don't play so
I just thought that it's interesting and
to what extent was this opening idea
dominating the game
it wasn't dominating at all because I
forgot what the intention of white in I
just only remembered that I'm you know
I'm stopping g5 so that's mainly the
thing in this decision was it
comfortable that trapping the Queen that
there was probably always a perpetual as
a plan-b perpetual attack on the Queen I
wasn't so sure there there is one but I
mean my calculation told me that there
has to be
I mean a safe way for me to play if if
something goes wrong but not sure about
the perpetual of the Queen but
definitely some positional compensation
like I've got after he played what I
calculated b6 and 94 yeah this Bishop
sacrifice on h7 is always exciting for
defense
how exciting is it for you to play it
yeah I mean if you get the chance to
play something that is
might get to some schoolbooks so always
good I'm from a point where you think
you were winning this game I thought
that after I mean Queen 874 after Queen
d3 I thought my chances became bigger I
was mainly considering I have 6 billion
which I thought is not the best
okay last question it's an amazing round
with a lot of fireworks on the boards
and do you think yesterday has a player
plays a role here yeah we realized that
being farmer is much tougher than being
a chess player so we decided to
concentrate on the game